you can't say what Don Lemon said in
2013 the degree to which we have already
been socially engineered in a mass scale
so how do we talk about recognizing how
do we even bring it up I don't know how
how can we discuss it right now because
I think it needs to be said it but he
was an embarrassment cut and Terry Crews
off like he did when Terry Crews was
essentially saying very much in tune
with what he thought oh no no no no
Terry Crews didn't go that far no you're
right he didn't even go you're
absolutely right ray oh he didn't even
go that far down lemon that's right went
on what I could only describe as a
racist white supremacist tirade by
today's standards yeah I guess I guess
so the things he was saying about the
black community if it was uttered today
by us or anybody would be an instant
perma ban and yet Thomas swallow says
very much a lot of the same stuff yep
he's talking about it and he's amazing I
think he's one of the man best best
lives that we have in America I'll just
put it this way what Don Lemon said
comes what you listen I'll do this
stefan molyneux was just banned from
YouTube and Twitter okay and I I would
be I'd be willing make a bet
to be fair I haven't I don't watch you
know I'm not super familiar with stefan
molyneux as content but i'd be willing
to bet the thing stefan molyneux said
probably came from Don Lemon yeah
talking about race and and their
behaviors and their choices and and what
that results in simply throwing trash on
the ground I mean I'm like wow because I
lived in cities and that is absolutely
true they don't care they toss the trash
bright on the ground and I'm not talking
raised no I'm talking that's everybody
and that's why I'm saying Don Lemon went
on what I would call a racist I read
your everyone exam it's true but I was
turning them specifically that's true on
lemon accused the black community of
specific things that are not unique to
the black community that exists for all
races that's true I agree
even if living in the city I've seen it
from all races it's not it wasn't Johnny
thirteen and twenty thirteen yeah so I
bring us up just to point out the degree
to which we have already been socially
engineered in a mass scale we
we don't even realize it but you go back
to this article from it's from I think
Ivan from CNN going back to 2013 and the
things that Don Lemon was saying about
clothing about fathers yeah it's from
Real Clear Politics in 2013 well I mean
it was from his show it's from his show
where he said Bill O'Reilly doesn't go
far enough and yeah that's it alone
Riley
well and you know what he does it twice
- yeah he quotes Bill O'Reilly and then
he goes you know what he's right but you
know what and he says more listen to
this then and then and then he goes bill
reilly says some more stuff diggin it a
little further and then he goes you know
what he's right but he still didn't go
enough he still didn't go to say it
enough that he should have said and then
he then he goes he's a list of five
things he says there's five things you
need to do this this Don Lemon video and
and with Terry Crews is important for a
couple reasons
it shows the degree to which mainstream
society has been radicalized yes and it
and it gives you a glimpse of what we
can no longer discuss correct if Don
Lemon was willing to say that Bill
O'Reilly didn't go far enough in 2013
and today he would argue with Terry
Crews when Terry Crews just says we're
all equal right the the the the reality
is people like to say you know like Tim
Tim got red polar whatever that's not
true Tim Poole is exactly where Tim pool
has been and true when I worked for a
defense well I worked well listen listen
I worked for Vice do you have an idea
what vice was doing you know in the
early 2010's
yeah like it was gross it was it was it
was edgy and stuff that's right when I
met you it was edgy stuff man and today
it's all woke feminism that's true so I
was talking to some people from Vice and
they said to me we realized it wasn't
you know specific people who changed
because like there's their specific bill
advice who were accused of being
right-wing and far right you know years
later and they said we realized it
wasn't them who changed it was us we
realized that certain things weren't
acceptable anymore and I said let me
stop you right there I was like do you
realize what you're saying you're saying
that from the perspective of regular
people that you were friends with that
created this company and worked with you
and helped you
and everything they stayed where they
were doing what was completely
acceptable you changed your behaviors
boom
so when you say they are far right you
realize they're not right you just kept
walking further and further loads are
far left that's correct
if these people weren't far right to
begin with they aren't today yep so when
I worked for fusion I had the same
opinions we were doing we were doing a
weak version of this show was it on a
street sweeper we worked we were doing
like the first iteration of this podcast
a couple episodes in 2014 I did well
that's right forgot about I did I did a
video about why I thought it was wrong
that there was segregated graduation
ceremonies being proposed at Harvard
yeah I did a video about Kesha and the
accusations the false act that contains
that were challenged yeah I remember
then I my stance on false allegations
and free speech enough stuff is exactly
where it's always been
hmm I've always been a moderate you know
aside from when I was younger but I mean
like in my my more recent career a
moderate left-leaning liberal working
for fusion working for vice they got
radicalized as evidenced very easily by
Don Lemon saying bill reilly doesn't go
far enough on CNN yeah 2013 so that was
from 2013 so I posted something on
Twitter that I noticed and it was not
from 2013 it was from 2017 and it was a
story of Monroe Bergdorf who got fired
from their job at Revlon for saying some
really stridently racist stuff that BLM
is saying now because Revlon just hired
them back because it was no longer
inappropriate to say those things that
BLM is saying can you hint at what the
conversation was about I don't have
you're allowed to say it yeah YouTube
yeah so Monroe just got on and was
saying stuff like you know the white man
is holding me down and everything you
know look at Colin Kapernick yeah yeah
was it three years ago signed a big huge
deal with Disney mm-hmm that has been a
dramatic radicalization oh yeah fast so
I'm in the same spot of Oz Ben I'm
chillin you know do my thing and I think
the important factor is what causes
someone to be radicalized is
friends being radicalized so I wondered
why it is that there's like one friend
of mine have known for years who has
gone surprisingly Marxist which is weird
I'm not kidding opposing anti-capitalist
stuff I'm like we talking about you're
like a wealthy like actor in Hollywood
were you doing I forget what what
clothing company some some clothing
company maybe I don't remember what it
was but they Armani maybe I don't know
they posted something about you know
capitalism like if it wasn't for
capitalism in World War two like you
know America wouldn't be selling weapons
I was like you know we won the war right
as you know because we joined the war we
helped defeat Germany in that war they
would have won yeah it was just like the
UK being are you forgetting that part of
it cuz capitalism actually won us the
war basically if you want to put it that
way well put it away like okay I started
wondering how it is this friend of mine
is posting Marxist memes okay right and
then I started seeing who they were
liking and who they were promoting in
their post and I was like interesting
hmm meme Marxist far lifelessness memes
and so then I thought about it and I'm
like you know I don't do anything but
work so I don't I don't go up to random
people like I don't hang off people and
then share ideas like that yeah
I've always done my thing reading the
news in my isolated you know send me
isolated kind of way where I sit down I
read the news for the past decade so I
follow similar people I've seen them get
radicalized I follow similar news
outlets I've seen they get read a lot
radicalized and these people don't
realize it because if they say that we
are the summation of the five people who
surround us but if the five people who
surround you are slowly being
radicalized and then you slowly start
agreeing with them not realizing you're
moving further and further left ten
years later you'll look to your right
and you'll see me far away and go wow
Tim became so far right and it's like
bro I've been standing in the same spot
I haven't moved
there's grim living in this van right by
the river here this is the river hasn't
moved either I am so there I am second -
with but grooves in it I'm sitting I
haven't moved man I follow a lot of the
exact same please don't talk about your
butt groove come on I follow a lot of
the families I always have and it's
funny when I see them post
and the hacker community is that is the
best example in my opinion these people
are the lowest of the low in the early
2010's
I was hanging out a hackerspaces friends
a lot of high profile ish hackers and
professors these people were all about
fighting authoritarianism defending the
right to free expression and free speech
now where are they completely in
opposition to it fully on board with
social justice authoritarianism my
favorite is that there was a guy during
Occupy Wall Street who approached me and
wanted to you know he's like I want you
to get involved with all these things
we're doing yeah and he worked with a
company with it with a nonprofit called
Free Press today regrets advocates for
censorship part they're one of the
organizations trying to boycott Facebook
and demanding censorship that's crazy
how do we get to a point where you don't
realize that if you you named your
organization Free Press and then
something happened where today you are
Pro censorship and that's what if your
core missions you realize like you've
been like zombified or you know you've
been turned the bad guys got you well
Don Lemon is definitely a different
version of himself from what I saw oh
yeah if he was that 2013 down them and
I'd want you know I'd love to see I'd be
like wow this guy he's standing up
Donald old things Donald Trump wouldn't
even say what he said no Donald Trump
would not say what Don Lemon said Don
Lemon made it a lot of points about the
behaviors of young black men and black
culture and things that are not unique
to black culture some of some of them
could be argued maybe but no not all of
them some of them could be argued that
what he was addressing affects everybody
actually what they could make a change
right well right the the the race part
of it is is what he added to it exactly
but it's more of a culture thing I think
as if you if you take a step back and
look look at it it's not talking up
talking about families and kids the way
he did yeah was like wow that was that
was right out of like tell me more about
how Terry Crews is wrong done lemon but
like the things you were saying huh you
would get that stuff from all right
YouTube videos it's true and Don Lemon
was saying at first that's absolutely
true
so the radicalization
the left it's crazy if you if you
haven't seen this video we can't play it
for you we can't read the words but it's
pretty bold and it is not the Don Lemon
that I've been see it's nothing I don't
want to pretend like it's the worst
thing in the world like he was spouting
out racial slurs no no it's not but it's
it's Don Lemon going on what I would
describe by today's standards is a
racist rant well and really and really
what it is resting is really what it is
is him saying you know it's not systemic
racism you need to do you need to step
up and look at yourself that's
essentially like if I could narrow down
what he said that's essentially what he
said one of the things we can highlight
is that he blames the black community
for littering which is absolutely not
unique to any race that's and that is
people not caring anymore well it's big
city as I see it a lot right but that's
why I would say that but it might add a
standard but he specifically said I
lived in a white neighborhood yeah and I
don't see anyone throwing trash on the
ground and then he specifically said I
mean I live in Harlem now and now I see
it everywhere
looks like there's so much wrong you
went there done you know what you went
there he's actually saying what that he
lived in a rich neighborhood oh and he
doesn't understand the difference yeah
that's a good point and he blames their
race for a Don Lemon is a racist I am I
am appalled by this video now hold on I
want to make sure I'm clear I don't
think what he said is the worst thing in
the world I do think it's it's it's got
racial he didn't need to go right like
he did bring it did it doesn't need to
bring to bring race into it yeah but I
do believe that if we actually read what
he said we would be flipping a coin on
whether or not YouTube would would give
us a strike and delete this video they
might allow us talk about on the grounds
that it's news newsworthy but if we if
we just repeated what he said like hit
the points made by Don Lemon oh that's a
strike hands down bone hands down hands
down like what you mentioned where he
says now you know now that I live in I
live in a white neighborhood I'll tell
you all the things though they did and
it's like yeah where I'm
multi-millionaire who move on
upper-class neighborhood yeah you're not
you you aren't in that class anymore you
can't you're speaking for people that
you don't understand anymore he didn't
he didn't move to the
the poor white suburbs of you know South
Chicago South with southwest suburbs of
Chicago right exactly where where there
was there's there's a suburb of Chicago
called Summit we call it scum it oh yeah
and it's and it's mostly white lower
income and I know people who live there
and there's a lot of drugs and it is not
Don Lemon you want talk about litter you
want to talk about community you need to
understand what poverty is and that's
why I think what he did was overtly
racist because he ignores the issues of
class and blames the race for what I
can't repeat it man we'll see we're
getting we're getting we're crop-dusted
on the danger - oh yeah I I feel like I
you you didn't want to do this story you
were kind of like me a little and I'm
like no no no we gotta talk about this
we can talk it wasn't that I was like I
was like you realize if we say what he
said writer of YouTube will delete the
stream well I think this is important
and you know what what what happens next
is really important - you know seeing
what happens what is CNN gonna do
because this just this just popped up
today like I saw this floating around -
there's someone someone tagged me in it
and and you know who you are appreciate
you for for tagging me than this and and
it's crazy and I will see cuz CNN
canceled culture like what are they
gonna do Don lemons one of their their
head figures right now you know yeah
here's if you want to find the video cuz
again I don't believe it isn't that bad
the people are saying it isn't racist
trust me man I'm telling you what he
said is YouTube animal search for Don
Lemon Bill O'Reilly doesn't go far
enough and you can watch what he said
yeah and there's a lot of people who
defend what he said but I think what the
point I'm making is not that I'm
agreeing or disagreeing or getting in
any part of that argument
I'm telling you that based on what he
said if you say that today if you record
that video and put it on Twitter Twitter
will ban you I mean hands down there are
people out there that are saying that I
said Thomas well Solo is saying it Larry
elders is out there saying this stuff -
there's there's there's like some
prominent figures out there but probably
our figures all we're gonna get banned
no no no the prominent figures tend to
get more leeway okay so during the learn
to code Fiasco I tweeted it a bunch of
times oh yeah did you never got
suspended
okay because they they I be
I bet YouTube has a coding system for
profiles that internal alright for
whether or not someone's a journalist or
whether or not someone's a celebrity or
sports ok and I'm making that guess
based on the fact that Twitter will do
anything for journalists because it's
the largest most active user base am i a
journalist now I don't know technically
I might get verified come on Oh what I
am honestly I'm on IMDB someone was like
you're on I'm to be I was like don't
take this away from me time that was
that I think we got it out though I mean
you people need to just look at look at
see it for themselves you know go watch
it I would make the point before we go
that Thomas soul and larry elder are
very very careful to say things like
this is a class issue it's that's very
true they're very precise in their
language yeah and they and they use a
lot of facts right they every single
thing that they say with facts and
history of and of the way that we wear
how we got here and and how how much
we've done to get here right which
people like to just ignore well let me
wrap up that whole conversation where
the point is when 230 reform happens
overnight that conversation that Don
Lemon had will come back like like a
like a dam breaking a flood sweeping
across the valley yep people will start
bringing these things up they'll start
talking about family they'll start
talking about the importance of free
speech and a culture education yep
you're all of these conversations will
come back and you don't even realize
they're gone
oh I can't wait to have conversations
again honestly this is our my job now
someone by I'm getting paid to have
conversations great so I went on and I
wanted to be okay I wanted to be
politically correct when I have a
conversation when I went on the Rogan
podcast with Dorsey yeah a lot of people
made a really good point they said why
are four liberals in a room talking
about what conservatives think and I
said that's a great point
you know Joe you should have a liberal
Anakin so
or to conservatives to come in and talk
about these off these issues actually
would be great if we'll Chamberlain who
is a lawyer and he runs Human Events
gave his perspective along with maybe
like a higher profile ben shapiro or
something on their view on just the
general culture around censorship both
about with a legal perspective you know
because typically these these arguments
have been right now the internet is all
liberals like conservatives exist and
there's a reason why they're all going
to parlor because they they are they're
walking on the razor's edge um moderate
you know liberal politically and there
is a what i described as kind of like a
temporary alliance between liberals and
conservatives real liberals yeah because
we agree on most things classic liberal
no no no like traditional or social
liberal like the liberals of the 90s and
the 2000s are classical liberal is a
right-wing position it's it's
center-right social liberals are center
left the center left and the right
liberal can mean anything now it is well
yeah right now people use it to just
mean leftist which is not true so what
i'm what i mean to say is of the 90s and
2000's and even the 2010s social
liberalism was like the default for the
democratic party it's very similar to
liberalism but it has a slant towards
social programs and civil rights issues
i would consider myself a social liberal
in that I want the 1964 Civil Rights Act
in in place yeah I want equality under
the law and all that stuff classical
liberals are more like free market less
government intervention but very similar
in that regard
mhm there's an alliance now between
conservatives traditional conservatives
dired conservatives and social liberals
the intellectual darkweb the politically
homeless because of the illiberal ISM of
the far left thanks for checking out
this clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you